-In the final hours before
polls open on election day,
Republicans are cycling through
one crazy stunt after another.
For more on this, it's time
for "a closer look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You might think that after
two years in total control
of the government, the party
in power would have a record
of achievements to run on.
But most at what Republicans
have done in office
has been deeply unpopular.
So instead they're furiously
throwing out
one new lie after another.
Like when Trump just made up
a fictional middle class tax cut
he said he was going to pass
before election day
even though Congress
isn't in session.
-We're looking at putting in
a very major tax cut
for middle-income people.
And if we do that, it will
be some time just prior,
I would say, to November.
-Major what again?
-A major tax cut.
We are going to be putting in
and are studying deeply right
now, 'round the clock,
a major tax cut.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I don't believe you're studying
anything around the clock.
I mean, your eye bags
say "all-nighter,"
But your grasp of policies
says, "In bed by 7:00."
But the real heart of the GOP's
closing argument
is its racist fearmongering
over the caravan of migrants
heading toward
the Southern border.
In reality, the caravan
is a few thousand
vulnerable people fleeing
poverty and violence,
but Trump keeps insisting
it's a gang full of criminals.
Trump's campaign
also produced an ad
calling the caravan an invasion.
The ad was obviously
and explicitly racist.
But before you get mad at Trump,
just know this is the first
he's hearing about it.
-Mr. President, several of the
networks have declined to run
your immigration ad
that you posted last week,
saying that it was potentially
too racist.
Do you have a response to that?
-I don't know about it.
I mean, you're telling me
something I don't know about.
-See, there you go.
He didn't know
anything about it.
The only problem is this was
the last part of that ad.
-I'm Donald Trump,
and I approve this message.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ] "I'm Donald Trump.
And I approve this message.
In fact, I've been working on it
around the clock."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] He's like a guy
who denies robbing a bank,
but forgets that he waved
at the security camera.
[ Laughter ]
Now, this ad was so racist
that CNN refused to air it.
And today, NBC and Fox News
said they would stop airing it.
Any network should have seen it
for what it was
and turned it down right away.
But unfortunately,
not everyone did.
-The president has been
criticized for a campaign ad
that is not only factually
incorrect,
it comes across to many
as simply racist.
CNN has refused to run the ad.
But NBC did air a shorter
version of the ad last night
during the Green Bay-New England
football game.
-You couldn't find anything else
to fill 30 seconds of ad time
during a game between
the Patriots and the Packers?
I mean, hell, just give us
a live stream of Tom Brady
on the sidelines
in that giant coat.
[ Laughter ]
in fact, you could tell
the ad was racist.
Because even the ad after it
was shocked.
-I'm Donald Trump.
And I approve this message.
-Dude, that's [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
[ cheers and applause ]
-And then, of course, there's
also Trump's racist stunt
over birthright citizenship.
Now automatic citizenship
for anyone born in this country
is a right enshrined
in the 14th Amendment.
And yet Trump has been insisting
he can just
unilaterally repeal it
through executive order,
something he obviously
cannot do.
-Just so you understand,
a person comes in,
was never in our country before,
has a baby,
and now all of a sudden the baby
is a United States citizen.
And through chain migration
and other things,
many other people
come in through the baby.
Hundreds of thousands
of children
born to illegal immigrants
are made automatic citizens
of the United States every year
because of this crazy,
lunatic policy.
-Why does he scream like that?
Sounds like he's doing
an impression
of Jerry Lewis
sitting on his own balls.
[ As Jerry Lewis ] "Automatic
citizens of the United States!"
[ Normal voice ] Also...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...why?
Why is he so obsessed
with babies?
Trump has been all over the map
on almost every issue
throughout his life.
But one thing he's been
very clear about,
he does not like babies.
-Our companies
have been just taken
like we're a bunch of babies.
We have a bunch of babies
running our country, folks.
We have a bunch of losers.
They're losers. They're babies.
Just for those babies out there
that keep talking about tariffs.
Oh, please. Please,
don't be a baby. Okay?
I know a lot of these things.
I mean I'm not a baby.
I know all these things.
-I know. But why do you --
-I'm not a baby.
-Nothing makes you sound
more like a baby than saying,
"I'm not a baby."
[ Laughter ]
if you're not a baby,
you don't have to clarify.
There's never a situation
where you're looking at someone
and you're like...
[ Laughter ]
...is that a baby?
And it turns out you're wrong.
This whole birthright
citizenship thing
is obviously just a racist stunt
designed to motivate
the GOP base.
Trump himself can't even exactly
explain how it would work.
Listener to him talk to
reporters and try to argue
that he doesn't need
a Constitutional amendment
to change the Constitution.
-Birthright citizenship is
a very, very important subject.
In my opinion, it's much less
complex than people think.
I think it says it very loud
and clear in the Constitution
that you don't have to go
through the process
of whatever they're
talking about.
-Oh, yes.
Sure, sure, sure. Sure, sure,
sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
[ Laughter ]
"The process of whatever
they're talking about."
That's exactly how the founders
laid it out in the Constitution.
-The Congress or whatever
it's called,
with the consent of whoever,
shall have the power to do
something to the thing,
you know, the big piece of paper
with all the laws on it.
What's it called?
Actually, never mind.
I forgot what I was
trying to say.
-Not only is this racist,
it's also infuriating
coming from a party
that has spent years
lecturing everyone else
about the Constitution.
For years, Republicans
have paid lip service
to the Constitution,
including Trump,
who repeated those
talking points
as a candidate and as president.
-We defend our Constitution.
And we believe in the wisdom
of our founders.
I feel very strongly
about the Constitution
and ruling through
the Constitution.
I'm proud of it. I love it.
And I want to go through
the Constitution.
That's what we want to do.
I mean, we want to bring
the Constitution back.
-Bring the Constitution back?
It didn't go anywhere.
it's the founding document
of our nation, not the McRib.
[ Laughter ]
And lying...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And lying about the caravan
isn't Trump's only
racist scare tactic.
In his desperation to fend off
a blue wave,
he's also back to implying
that former President Obama
is not American.
Trump was in Indiana campaigning
against Democratic Senator
Joe Donnelly and said this.
-It's no surprise that
Joe Donnelly is holding a rally
this weekend
with Barack...
[ Spectators booing ]
..."H" Obama.
-Aw, go "F" yourself.
No one...
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. Mnh-mnh. No, no, no.
No one wants to see
your racist charades.
Although you know Trump
is the guy when he plays
charades who just answers
during the question.
"Movie, one word, 'Jaws.'"
[ Laughter ]
Trump is running a campaign
of racist incitement.
And that's because he and his
allies know that keeping people
angry and afraid is one way
they can stay in power.
In fact,
that's a point Obama made
at a rally in Florida on Friday.
-Why is it the folks
that won the last election
are so mad all the time?
[ Crowd cheering ]
It's an interesting question.
I mean, like,
when I won the presidency,
at least my side
felt pretty good.
-I love that Trump is out there
losing his mind,
throwing out one insane
conspiracy theory after another
and Obama's just like,
"You mad, bro?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, man, I am --
I am so, so happy
funny Obama is back
and he's got new material.
I guess that Netflix deal
he signed is really working out.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Obama ] "You, uh...
you hear about this caravan?
The only van, uh,
Trump should be thinking about
is a moving van.
And he looks like
he's ready to move.
You see those bags
under his eyes?
[ Laughter ]
Those bags are packed.
Uh...what else?
[ Laughter ]
This election...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hey, Melania, help me get
these bags...
into the overhead."
[ Laughter ]
But, Melania,
she's not on the plane.
He's going up one stairs.
She's going down the other.
Uh, what else?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
This election has made clear
what the modern GOP
has become --
a party that traffics
in open racism
and sells its voters
culture war rhetoric
while enriching themselves
at taxpayers' expense.
They're hoping racist
fearmongering
will distract you
while they rob you.
And they're hoping you won't
care if the president is a...
-Crazy lunatic.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪